hello you guys what's up it is me larae
and i'm here with buzzfeed talking about
my first times
first thing you do when you wake up in
the morning um which is so crazy is that
i literally just woke up i'm not even
getting five minutes ago i threw on
blush and foundation um but the first
thing i do is i go straight to the
coffee um shop i go to this place called
coffee figs it's my favorite place right
now they have the best grown paninis my
coffee order is a hazelnut latte with
oat milk but if i'm feeling crazy crazy
i'll get a cold brew telling my secrets
of where i go in the morning it's gonna
probably suck because now people are
gonna go and just honestly the lion's
gonna be long as [ __ ] and i'm not gonna
be able to get my panini first album you
bought i would say would have to be
miley cyrus bangers that's the reason
why i created my name and i feel like
that was like my whole like era of like
becoming a consumer of albums i used to
tweet miley cyrus every day i had to
delete some tweets because it was
getting a little obsessive but my name
was larae cyrus and i took up the cyrus
part because that's obviously not my
legal name and i probably would have got
sued by now um which is crazy is that
she dm'd me because i was supposed to
work with her for um something and i was
freaking out that
i had to have my manager respond because
literally i was like oh my god i love
you you're a queen you slay like prayer
mama girl like it was just so bad and
unfortunately due to my schedule was
being so awful i couldn't work with her
and then she unfollowed me but i met her
team recently at the cinderella premiere
and they said that like she is still
down to work with me so that's dope she
needs to re-follow me miley i will
literally pay you monthly for a follow
i'll do a down payment too babe let's go
first ever concert you went to i'm
probably gonna get eight alive for this
but it was this um emo band back in my
like emo days i went to van's warp tour
do you all know what that is i wanna go
see blood on the dance floor paid 300
for a ticket just saw one band and
literally left first time you ever went
viral basically it was like a skit and i
made this character called clitoria yeah
it was a dark place i'm not gonna lie
you know the video was not honestly that
funny i think people were just laughing
at me rather with me so if y'all want to
find that you totally can if you don't
want to find that you're saving so much
time in your life that you don't need to
waste first an accurate room you heard
about yourself the only rumor that i can
think of is people getting my ethnicity
wrong it's like a huge conversation i
guess but so many people try to say that
i'm so many different things like yeah
like literally larae is like japanese
and like persian i'm like
the first a-list celebrity that followed
you can i check honestly i'm gonna go
with miley i feel like it's on brand
that's the only like person i'm probably
freaked out over or i'll consider a
little celebrity in my eyes my first big
purchase was my porsche and then it
broke and so i no longer have her my mom
crashed it well she technically didn't
crash it my mom got hit in my car well
she wasn't in the car let me clarify
because they're probably like what the
um so i let my mom use my car for a
little bit and she was parked and um
someone hit it and it just got totaled
from there shout out to her like mom you
did that first love you heard from after
your song cancelled actually one of my
friends is friends with billy eilish and
she said that billy listened to it and
um she laughed a lot which i think is so
dope because it's really stylish and
also lil yachty which is kind of funny
he actually reacted to it in my room him
and his friends came over which is a
little weird because like lil yachty
in my house no whatever yeah he reacted
to it and he said it wasn't terrible
first big date when me and um brady went
to catalina island we took a helicopter
and it was like for a two-year
anniversary first city come on english
senior anniversary um it was so cute i
also got the vaccine at the time so i
was dying but he made sure that i was
like having a great time which is really
cute first kiss yeah i think i remember
that you know i just be kissing
everybody i think it resets every year
my recent one i would say was one my
birthday july 22nd first hard lesson
you've learned living in the public eye
when i used to like be a stan account i
used to always listen to everything i
would hear on the internet and i'm like
oh my god like this person's evil but um
now being and seeing these people for
who they are in real life and then
seeing the rumors that they you know
portray them as online it's like don't
listen to everything you hear which is
so corny and a lot of people say but
it's honestly the truth don't judge a
book by its cover that's the most
corniest analogy but it's almost the
truth first time you talked or slashed
matt brady orlando we were at a party
and i thought he was so fine i'm not
really into like the whole like making
the first move thing because you know a
girl got social anxiety i didn't make
the first move and i said hi i'm larae
he goes you're so beautiful and gorgeous
and your ass looks stuff out today and i
said thanks and now we're dating forever
in paris um i had fans literally
i would say about like 40 of them a day
stay outside of my hotel and chase my
car and then follow where we're going i
would never forget that moment because
the amount of i felt like i was like the
walking dead and having all those kids
chase my car it was such a dope
experience and i felt like kylie jenner
or like beyonce thank you buzzfeed you
guys are the sweetest i am larae and
those are my first time so if you guys
enjoyed if you guys want to try some
fire mac and cheese go to the raised mac
dot com also like stream my song because
why not and yeah have a nice day bye
guys
[Music]
[Music]